and there is thomas eshelman's number
down at triple a norfolk uh so owen
three high era
you know he's a contact guy i mean
that's uh you know that's what he does
uh doesn't strike a lot of guys out not
that he can't
but he's not gonna throw it by you his
average fastball is going to be probably
85 to 87.
change up curveballs sliders and he gets
him
so eshelman strikeout pachette down and
two down here in the first
boy has he hit hard down to third
no problem for franco and it's a quick
one two three inning thomas echelman
sets down the blue jays orioles coming
to bat no score
yeah so start number 13 he's only given
up more than three runs twice he look at
that 92 strikeouts
70 and a third inning cedric mullins
t-shirt night a lot of orange around the
ballpark
that's hit well way back and out of here
on t-shirt night cedric mullen says yes
i'm here for you fans
touch em all cedric mullins home run
number 10.
the 2-1 and goriel gets into one sends
it to left it's deep and it's gone
number seven on the season for goriel
and that'll tie the game up at one
just a matter of time for the blue jay
second time through the lineup as
they're starting to get the timing down
now against eshelman
[Applause]
panic lines went into right field for a
base hit a one-ounce single here in the
fifth
and espionage
for a base hit and he's going to succeed
franco charging the only play was to
bare-handed he couldn't come up with it
and it's a bunt single for espinal
pushing panic to second
just catch it you've got a glove
they're giving you an out because you
you're in
you just can't you just it's just a low
percentage play
panic at second santiago at first
there's the ground ball
one there onto first and they turned two
bang bang play at first but the orioles
get the double play to end the inning
let's see if the blue jays want to take
a look at that yeah well everything kind
of goes into a freeze frame here espinal
gets down there pretty quickly i wonder
if he interfered is they're going to
take a look
so perfect double play ball if
you can get the
throw a little bit off not a legal slide
[Music]
he's safe they're going to ask for a
challenge
tabby and they're going to overturn this
one foot is down
there balls still a foot or two away
from the glove
that's an easy call for me how about the
long strides of riley adams to get down
that line to beat it out i think the
orioles know that this inning is going
to continue
to set the pitch
he got him
tyler wells with his strikeout of simeon
he pumped 96 by him on the outside
corner and he strands men at the corner
2-2 to valencia
fine drive pat felika's got his second
hit of the game
and they're playing right there
hit hard backhand into right center
field
samian got the backhand over there but
couldn't bring it in and it's a base hit
for mullins cedric's second hit of the
game and now he leads
major league baseball and hits
2-2 little looper to left field and it's
down for a base hit
mullins will stop at third valaika
scores and the orioles lead it 2-1
2-2
and he has popped him up looks like
thornton will ultimately win the battle
espinal is there and thornton does well
to get out of that a couple of men
stranded but the orioles do have the
lead back
after 13 pitches didn't do that
[Applause]
freddie takes a pitch up high where he
loves it and lines it into center field
thornton looking for a ground ball here
or he'll take the strikeout two-two
curveball down and away to get him out
number two swing and a miss to get
valaka nice job by thornton
[Music]
breaking ball hammered way back in right
field and it's off the scoreboard
galvez heading to second here's the
throw he's in with an rbi double
and the orioles lead it three to one
there's the line drive base hit right
field
galveston third has the green light here
comes the throw to the plate it's up the
line and galves is in
and the orioles lead it four to one
2-2 to severino
line drive base hit into center field
bronco will stop at second
and the orioles keep it going here their
fourth hit in the inning
a swing and a high fly ball right field
is this one out
you better believe it
mullins makes it 7-1 orioles
somebody send this man to colorado
and you hope trey mancini is stepping
out for him i don't know if cedric gets
it we're trying to get him up
here he comes
wow
one two on the way
and down on strikes goes hayes
but not before the orioles put up a five
spot on the blue jays and on cedric
mullins night cedric mullins delivers
second home run of the game the three
run shot and the orioles have some
breathing room on top seven to one take
a bow cedric
and paul fry trying to finish it off jim
yeah not exactly what we thought but
what we envisioned talking about they
need to get more save opportunities
because he's kind of become the
pitcher of choice in the late innings
back to a full count now on guerrero
did he get him
yes he did
roberto ortiz rings him up down at first
base no argument
my ball left field this should do it
wilkerson is there and the orioles
have ended their losing streak
wow what a game mullins starts it off
kind of finishes it thomas seshelman not
exactly a household name yet
really well four and two thirds innings
nice to get off the losing streak
there's the man of the hour cedric
mullins orioles a 7-1 winner tonight